all right should we do this
now by the way uh they always should
supply a domain for these questions
right but
uh because you know this has an infinite
number of solutions as you go from
along the x-axis um but you know if you
didn't get given one what would you
assume
yeah it's not a bad assumption to make
at all
okay so let's have a go at this okay now
what can we do with this
already like right at the start you can
see you need your double angle uh
expansion
right so let's see how you're going from
this morning
this is a fraction just to help you out
okay something on something is for 10x
so how does the tan double angle
expansion begin
can anyone remember yeah
yeah with no can you remember how
pointless don't read it
i can read it off i've memorized is
there can anyone is anyone not booked
already yeah
yeah good almost one minus yep that's
okay
we just learned it right you've really
got to get these into your brain yeah i
i remember it being really tough because
they all look very similar to each other
the main way you all learn these is by
using them
okay and it's also you know just write
it down so every time it just
there's a thing um that writing does
which typing doesn't not that you would
type this anyway
because that would actually take forever
still but it actually engages a part of
your mind that has through the memory so
do it okay
all right now what do i do at this point
um what what options do i have
i'm going to have to probably cross
multiply to get this guy over the other
side
so i've got 210x
and this is going to be uh 4 tan x minus
4 10 cubed right
okay now it's tempting to divide through
by 10x at this point because it's a
common factor and it would get rid of
this
cube business which looks really gross
right um however that's going to cause
you problems right because for instance
if i gave you this equation okay and you
divided through by x which would
be legitimate you'd say x equal to one
and that
is where you would stop okay but you'll
know at this point this is
this would be a parabola right quadratic
equation so you're expecting two
solutions
okay maybe it is it's a double root but
in this case it's not
which you would reveal if you factor out
right so instead of
dividing through you'd take one term
over
and then you would factorize and then
you can see it's not just one
it's also x equals zero okay so
big important rule don't divide through
instead
let's gather some like terms and see
what happens okay so
if i take that 210x over i've got 2
10 x here and 4 10
cubed x okay unlike with the tan x i can
actually divide through by two
because you won't lose any solutions if
you divide by just a constant
right so here i'll have tan x minus
so that's terrible 2 10 cubed
x and the reason why um
the cube is no big problem is because
when you factorize
you end up with this which is really
quite reasonable okay so now what we've
done is we've
used our knowledge of expansions to turn
this back into a problem which
you knew how to solve in your town okay
but maybe you don't remember
what to do at this point what's what can
you do
i've paused here because i factorized as
far as i can go
okay this is a product there's one of
your factors and there's the other one
when you've got a factorizing problem
like this much like here you take both
sides
or both factors sorry you say this can
be equal to 0
and then this can be equal to 0. so i'm
going to break it apart
into 2. i'm going to solve 10x
that's one factor that can be zero or
this guy one minus two
tan squared x equals zero that's my
other factor which could also be equal
to zero
okay now tan x
equals zero what's the first place your
brain goes to solve that what would you
do
zero okay what else
and that's it that's the where that's
all of the domain that we've covered so
we're done
okay now it's interesting i'm just
watching you sort of go
which is which is the sound of
uncertainty so how can you know i can be
really shocked
okay i was just imagining that's this
that's the sound the graph makes in my
here's what i suggest you do instead now
some of you
some of you will not like this approach
because you do not like what it requires
however
um you're going to need to get good at
this anyway so i figure
you might as well the way i appreciate
my brain rather than making sounds
is i graph it okay now tan x equals zero
tan x is such a common curve you really
ought to know what it looks like okay so
if you're like man this thing takes so
long
treat it as an investment because the
more times you do this the quicker you
will get it doing it
okay uh until the point where you can
see it in your head without actually
drawing it now
between 0 and 360. what does
10x look like okay well you've got one
branch
and then see that sound was totally
unrealistic because
this graph has discontinuities in it
right don't try please
can anyone beatbox dubstep anyway so
there's uh
there's 0 to 360.
and i'm interested in when that graph is
equal to zero